وفي ملفات الحرب باوكرانيا قال نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري ان نيه
المصنعه للدبابات فتح فرع لها في كييف
مؤشر على استمرار اوكرانيا بنهجها في
التصعيد واكد من ان روسيا ستربح بافتتاح
مصنع في اوكرانيا برشقه من الصواريخ مضيفا
انه في حاله قرر الالمان بناء المصنع على
ارض الواقع فان بلاده تنتظر الترحيب
بمشروعهم بفارغ الصبر
من جانبها اكدت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسولا فوندرلاين انه سيتم توقيع قرار
انشاء المركز الدولي للمحاكمه بهدف محاسبه
روسيا جراء حربها على اوكرانيا
تسبب الغزو الروسي بمعاناه لا توصف في
اوكرانيا منذ عام تقريبا اكتشف العالم
وفضاء كنت هناك بنفسي وشاهدت الفضاء التي
ارتكبتها القوات الروسيه هناك ادله
متزايده على الهجمات المباشره ضد المدنيين
وكذلك على الطاقه والبنيه التحتيه القوات
الروسيه ارتكبت التعذيب وسوء المعامله
والعنف الجنسيه والاعدام يجب تحميل روسيا
مسؤوليه هذه الجرائم المروعه ويجب محاسبه
بوتين يجب علينا ان نفعل كل ما في وسعنا
لتقديم الجولات الى العداله يؤيد الاتحاد
الاوروبي دور المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
نعتقد ايضا انه يجب ان تكون هناك محكمه
مخصصه لمقاضره جريمه العدوان الروسيه
سنوقع
في هذا المؤتمر اتفاقيه انشاء المركز
الدولي لمحاكمه جريمه العدوان في لاهاي
سيواصل الاتحاد الاوروبي العمل مع الشركاء
حتى تدفع روسيا الثمن اننا نقف متحدين من
اجل العداله لاوكرانيا
وحول اعلان اوكرانيا حاله التاهب تخوفا
طبعا من هجوم الروسيه محتمل حاله تاهب جوي
معنا من دوناتسك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر اهلا بك رائد ما خلفيات هذا القرار
وهذا الاعلان
مساء الخير ميسون بالفعل العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا تشهد تطورا كبيرا
خلال الفتره الاخيره وما بين يوم والاخر
تستهدف روسيا
مراكز لانتاج الطاقه في اوكرانيا في جميع
المدن الاوكرانيه
ومصانع للاسلحه وتقول انها تستهدف ايضا
قواعد عسكريه اوكرانيه لا تنكر روسيا
قصفها لهذه
القواعد العسكريه او هذه المحطات في
اوكرانيا لكن الاهم من ذلك هو زياره وزير
الدفاع الروسي اليوم للمناطق العسكريه في
دانيتك ميسون بالفعل كانت هناك زياره
مفاجئه لوزيره الدفاع الى مناطق الاعمال
العسكريه خاصه في المناطق الجنوبيه من
دانياسكانا وزير الدفاع يتفقد مسار
العمليه العسكريه واشرف على تدريب
المستجدين من الجنود الروسي الذين
وصلوا الى المنطقه العسكريه بعد استدعائهم
للتعبئه الجزئيه منذ اواخر العام الماضي
بالفعل هذه كانت اشاره من وزير الدفاع الى
الانتقادات التي وجهها له او للقاده
العسكريين قائد مجموعه فاقنر بروجن الذي
قال بان القاده العسكريين الروسي يجلسون
في مكاتبهم ولا يعرفون شيئا عن الاعمال
العسكريه او ما يعانوها جنود الروس في ارض
المعركه طبعا المحور الهام هو محور باقمت
لا يفوتنا ان نعرج على محور باقمت حيث
قاربت يعني
24 ساعه الاخيره التي
منحها قائد قوات فاغنر للرئيسه الاوكراني
زيلينسكي لسحب قواته من مدينه باخمه يعني
يوم امس واليوم واظن من صباح الغد تكون
المهله قد انتهت ومن المفروض ان يكمل طوق
المدينه لانه ترك طريقا وحيدا في الناحيه
الغربيه طريق الذي يصل باقي متقاله
بريكوجن بان هذا الطريق هو الوحيد وافضل
ان تسحب القوات الاوكرانيه خلال هذه
الفتره بالفعل توقفت الاعمال العسكريه
التي كانت مستعره في المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه حول مدينه خرومافا وبقدانوفكا
لوقت انهاء هذه المهله اما القوات
العسكريه الخاصه الروسيه اقصد قوات
فاجنرفا تقدمت في عمق المدينه وصلت الى
قلب المدينه من ثلاثه نواحي كما نعرف
الجنوب والشمال والشرق ويعني المنطقه
الوسطى لم تسيطر عليها وتعتبر المنطقه
اسمحي لي ميسون من الوسط حتى الغرب هي تحت
سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
لتعزيز بامدادات عسكريه او حتى لسحب
القوات
العربيه رائد الاخضر شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المعلومات